someone just left a dog  in the parking lot  in a cage  and in 100 degree heat this young dog  though was discovered just in time he  was dumped outside of a thrift store  owned by an animal rescue group now  leaving a dog in the elements like this  can be a death sentence now home for  spot who owns that thrift shop says they  get 30 to 40 calls a day from owners who  are needing help but this is not the  answer  i say if you can just give me two weeks  and foster let me see if i can get that  dog into a home for you you know or what  can i do financially to help you  lately though some owners are choosing  to ditch the dogs maybe tying them to  trees or dumping them like this little  guy but he was lucky remember once it  hits 105 degrees it's illegal to tether  a dog or deprive them of water in the  city of las vegas it's actually part of  their animal cruelty laws once you get  to that certain temperature you need to  provide them a secondary source of shade  or water